♪ ♪
>> Tucker: LAST NIGHT WE
TALKED TO THE GOVERNOR OF
ARKANSAS, A REPUBLICAN CALLED
ASA HUTCHINSON, JUST VETOED A
BILL THAT BANNED THE CHEMICAL
CASTRATION.
WE ASKED HIM WHAT HE DID THAT,
HE WAS GRACIOUS ENOUGH TO
EXPLAIN.
EARLY IN OUR CONVERSATION, IT
BECAME CLEAR THAT
GOVERNOR HUTCHINSON HAD NOT DONE
A LOT OF RESEARCH INTO THE
TOPIC.
A LOT OF THINGS HE DIDN'T SEEM
TO KNOW, FOR EXAMPLE, IN
FEBRUARY 1 OF THE OLDEST MEDICAL
JOURNALS THE WORLD SUMMARIZED
RESEARCHERS FINDINGS ON PUBERTY
BLOCKERS.
HERE'S WHAT THEY FOUND.
THE PUBERTY USED TO TREAT
CHILDREN 12 TO 15 THAT HAVE
GENDER DYSPHORIA HAD NO
SIGNIFICANT EFFECT ON THEIR
PSYCHOLOGICAL FUNCTION, THOUGHTS
OF SELF HARM OR BODY IMAGE.
THE CHILDREN EXPERIENCE REDUCED
GROWTH IN HEIGHT AND BONE
STRENGTH.
THERE IS FACT, KEEP IN MIND.
THE GOVERNMENT SAID CHILDREN
NEEDED THESE DRUGS IN ORDER TO
NOT BECOME CLINICALLY DEPRESSED.
THIS SUGGESTS THEY DON'T HELP,
ONLY HURT THEIR BODIES.
THERE OTHER STUDIES, ONE
CONDUCTED BY THEY HAVE STARK
CLINIC, THAT IT HAS INCREASED
INCIDENCES OF SELF HARM AND
SUICIDAL IDEATION.
THOSE ARE THE ONLY STUDY SET UP
ON THAT.
BRITAIN'S NATIONAL INSTITUTE OF
HOW SAFE IS VERY LOW EVIDENCE
SUPPORTING THE IDEA THAT THE
PUBERTY BLOCKERS SHOULD NOT BE
GIVEN TO CHILDREN.
THOSE DRUGS MAY MAKE IT WORSE.
AT THE MOST THOROUGH
PEER-REVIEWED STUDY ON THE TOPIC
WAS CONDUCTED IN SWEDEN.
RESEARCHERS FOLLOW THE OUTCOMES
OF THOSE WHO HAD UNDERGONE
REASSIGNMENT SURGERY.
TEN TO 15 YEARS AFTER THEY WENT
UNDER THE SURGERY, THE SUICIDE
RATE HAD JUMPED BY MORE THAN
2000%.
I WAS THAT A VICTORY?
IT'S NOT, IT'S A TRAGEDY.
WE ASKED HIM ABOUT ANY RESEARCH
HE MIGHT'VE READ THAT
CONTRADICTED THESE FACTS.
HE CLEARLY HADN'T READ ANY OF
THE CONTRADICTING FACTS.
WE HAD WERE LED TO WONDER, HOW
WERE THEY CONVINCED THAT VETOING
THIS BILL WAS A GOOD IDEA?
>> YOU CLEARLY AREN'T FAMILIAR
WITH THE RESEARCH.
MY QUESTION IS, HAVE YOU SPOKEN
TO ANY OF THE BIGGEST EMPLOYERS,
COMPANIES IN ARKANSAS, ABOUT
THIS QUESTION MIGHT HAVE YOU
TAKEN ANY CALLS FROM TYSON'S,
DILLARD, WALMART?
ANY OF THOSE COMPANIES CALLED
YOU ABOUT THIS BILL?
>> NO.
>> Tucker: I WANT TO BE CLEAR,
HAVE YOU SPOKEN TO ANY CORPORATE
INTERESTS IN THE STATE OF
ARKANSAS ABOUT THIS BILL?
>> TUCKER, ANSWERED THAT
QUESTION, AND I SAID, NO I HAVE
NOT.
>> Tucker: ASA HUTCHINSON WAS
QUITE DEFINITIVE ON THAT.
WE HAD TO TAKE HIS WORD FOR IT.
HE WAS VERY EMPHATIC.
IT LOOKS LIKE, HOW DO WE PUT
BEST, LYING.
THE DAY WE SPOKE TO HIM, IN
FACT, THE WALTON FAMILY ENDORSED
HIS DECISION TO VETOED THE BILL
THAT HAD PASSED THE LEGISLATURE.
NOT JUST ANY FAMILY, THE RICHEST
FAMILY IN THE WORLD COME OF
COURSE, THE MOST POWERFUL FAMILY
AND ARKANSAS.
THEY WANTED ASA HUTCHINSON TO
KNOW THAT HE HAD DONE EXACTLY
WHAT THEY WANTED HIM TO DO.
"WE SUPPORT ASA HUTCHINSON'S
RECENT VETO, ANY POLICY THAT
LIMITS INDIVIDUAL OPPORTUNITY
ALSO LIMITS OR STATES
POTENTIAL."
IF WALMART IS GOING TO SELL A
LIFETIME SUPPLY OF DRUGS TO
TRANSMUTE, IT WOULD BE NICE IF
YOU COULD VETO LEGISLATION AND
ANY BILLS LIKE IT.
IT'S POSSIBLE HE IGNORED THE
WISHES OF HIS FAMILY, ALTHOUGH
HE COULDN'T FIND ANY EXPERTS WHO
AGREE WITH THEM.
HE SPOKE TO SOMEONE TODAY WHO
SAYS, HE WOULD VERY MUCH LIKE A
BOARD SEAT AT WALMART WHEN HE
LEAVES.
JUST A FEW DAYS AGO, HE APPEARED
ON THIS NETWORK TO ADMIT THAT
BEFORE MAKING ANY DECISIONS ON
TRANSGENDER ISSUES, HE FIRST
CONSIDERS WHAT MAJOR GLOBAL
CORPORATIONS THINK.
>> THE HOME OF SOME MAJOR GLOBAL
CORPORATIONS HERE IN ARKANSAS,
CERTAINLY WORRIED ABOUT THE
IMAGE OF OUR STATE, BUT WE ARE
TRYING TO SEND THE SIGNAL THAT
YOU CAN PROTECT CONSCIENCE, YOU
CAN PROTECT THE GIRLS IN SPORTS
WITHOUT BEING DISCRIMINATORY,
AND TRYING TO SAY, WE ARE NOT
DIVERSE AND TOLERANT OF
DIFFERENT LIFESTYLES.
THAT'S IMPORTANT FOR US AS A
STATE, AND WHAT WE HAVE TO
ACHIEVE AS A NATION.
>> Tucker: WE ARE THE HOME OF
SOME MAJOR GLOBAL CORPORATIONS,
GOVERNOR HUTCHINSON SAID.
THEY WORRY ABOUT THE IMAGE OF
THE STATE, LESS ABOUT THE
CHILDREN OF THE STATE, WHO IF,
IF EACH AND DOMINIC ASA HUTCHINS
IN CHARGE, HE WOULD BE
CHEMICALLY -- BY DOCTORS.
WE WILL